for millions of europeans the summer of
2022 has been sweltering a dry spring
and hotter than that usual temperatures
have left several european countries in
the grip of drought
extreme heat waves and forest fires have
plagued france italy spain and portugal
for weeks
the uk has recorded temperatures over 40
degrees celsius for the first time
and rivers on the continent are drying
up in the netherlands and germany the
river rhine has dropped so low that
houseboats have become stranded and
commercial ships can't carry full loads
anymore
let's get more on this from our
correspondent barbara basil she's in
nijmegen in the netherlands barbara the
rhine is one of the world's most
important shipping lanes is there enough
water left in it to keep the boats
moving
there is just a bit water left in the
rhine here right behind me but on the
other side terry what you're seeing
there are beaches and they're not
supposed to be any beaches there is
supposed to be water over there so the
barges the rhine barges that go down to
the harbor the biggest harbor in europe
rotterdam they are just inching past
here very slowly and they're riding
extremely high in the water they can
only take about a third of their normal
load
and that means it the the price of
course for the transport triples so for
them this might be the last days today
maybe tomorrow
towards the end of the week shipping
might totally stop here because they
hardly have any water left under under
the ships and they can hardly move
anymore
stay with us barbara as we get a closer
look now at how drought is affecting the
rhine overall
water levels have dropped so low that
it's now possible to walk in the river
and not just alongside it
where water once flowed now it's just
stones and gravel and at one point it's
actually possible to walk from one side
to the other
experts say it will likely remain this
way for some time
because of the low water levels the use
of the rhine is limited and the
transport capacity of the inland
waterway fleet is therefore lower
this also means that all those who
transport goods and services via the
waterway obviously have lower supply
possibilities
this has led to major economic problems
companies are unable to transport goods
along the river
many containers are jammed at various
points on the rhine
barge operators have reported that they
can no longer fully load their ships
we have to analyze every trip
every order we accept we have to
consider how much water the river still
has what many people don't know is that
when we set sail at water level there's
only between 10 and 30 centimeters of
water still under the ship in the
shallow places
the federal government has plans to
deepen the river the first test
boreholes have been drilled in the
central rhine region
experts hope to deepen parts of the
river by up to 20 centimeters over the
next 10 years
barbara we just heard there that there
are plans to make the rhine a little bit
deeper how is that going to help things
though if there isn't enough water
that is the big question here of course
it will help because the ships can keep
moving a bit longer but it's not going
to add any water to the rhine basically
we don't know the ecological problems
that maybe created experts some experts
are warning
not to do that the ecological problems
that will be created by deeping earning
the shipping channel here so this is of
course where we see one of the problems
uh economic desires and and wishes uh on
the other hand uh opposed to like
ecological considerations because many
people say you shouldn't do that to the
rhine it would have untold consequences
so the water is just simply running out
here and the the drought will continue
in the netherlands they expect in the
next week a
week another heat wave so the level is
going to go down and down and nothing is
going to change that
so there's less water in the rhine and
there are wildfires all over europe
extremely high temperatures this is a
big problem for europe in general how is
the european union addressing this issue
barbara
the eu is trying to say we are going to
get climate neutral within the next
decade however
the the damages that we see this summer
that are so incredibly uh
bad all over europe as you mentioned
droughts and wildfires and there's no
water in parts of the netherlands
already this is one of the wettest
countries in europe so those can there
is no remedy for that this is what has
already happened and it seems that
politics also on the european level are
just slowly sort of
trying to catch up with a development
and ecological development that is
happening under our very eyes
barbara thank you so much our
correspondent barbara basilda in the
netherlands